[Musique]
bonsoir François Bayrou merci d'être
notre invité vous êtes président du
MoDem maire de Pau mais aussi au
commissaire aux plans et on va parler
bien sûr de cette réforme des retraites
sur lequel vous aviez fait une note en
tout cas la situation du régime de
retraite depuis le 8 décembre dernier
mais avant d'évoquer ce sujet il y a
deux questions d'actualité j'ai envie de
dire en ce 8 mars le président Macron a
annoncé un projet de loi sur
l'introduction de l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse l'IVG dans la
Constitution liberté alors oui de la ça
c'est la rédaction de ce projet de loi
ce n'est pas oui faut être précis vous
voulez dire c'est pas l'obligation c'est
pas là c'est la réaffirmation si j'ai
bien compris c'est la réaffirmation que
c'est une liberté reconnue en France
pour les femmes
et pour moi il y a au moins un il y a un
point positif dans cette affaire c'est
que si on en était resté à l'idée d'une
proposition de loi
alors ça signifie un référendum
obligatoire sur ce sujet je précise que
c'était l'idée d'Aurore berger qui en
avait fait une proposition de loi mais
qui espérait que ce soit repris par le
gouvernement et pour moi en tout cas
c'était un très grand risque parce que
se saisir de sujet qui emporte autant la
conscience personnelle les
interrogations d'un certain nombre de
courants
majoritaire en France
par personne et ce que ce que le
président de la République propose selon
une rédaction que je trouve alors
celle-là tout à fait
acceptable c'est on réaffirme et ceux
qui ont proposé ça ont eu raison de le
faire on réaffirme que cette liberté est
protégée oui donc vous va très cette
proposition et vous serez favorable à la
réunion d'un congrès plutôt qu'un
référendum si je comprends bien je pense
que le que le le président de la
République n'imagine pas qu'on est un
référendum sur ce sujet
non pas que il y aurait des doutes sur
le résultat mais
à la fois
l'opinion très profondément et favorable
depuis longtemps c'est maintenant établi
depuis des décennies et en même temps
vous voyez bien qu'il y a des milieux
qui
spirituel religieux pour qui c'est un
cas de conscience et donc
inutile d'en faire un sujet
d'affrontement dans le pays alors que
c'est désormais une zone de rencontre
des opinions mais ce sera inscrit donc
cette liberté dans la Constitution si
c'était adoptée et par et notamment par
le Congrès autre question
Eric Dupond-Moretti a-t-il franchi une
ligne rouge alors que la majorité
critique les excès des insoumis en
faisant deux bras d'honneur comme il l'a
reconnu lui-même alors il dit à la
présomption d'innocence mais Olivier
Leix le président de Allaire dit c'était
quand même en ma direction
la démocratie française et la démocratie
parlementaire française file du mauvais
coton ça va pas il y a des mots
des invectives des gestes
qui sont
profondément déplacés et qui ont deux
effets qui sont délétères l'un et
l'autre le premier c'est que les
Français regardent ce spectacle
stupéfait en se disant mais où on va où
cela va-t-il s'arrêter est-ce qu'il y a
des limites où on va encore chaque jour
découvrir un psychodrame nouveau
certains vous diront que dans les sous
la Troisième sous la Quatrième
République on a eu notamment sur la
troisième
sous la troisième et la Quatrième
République qui avait pas de télévision
les mots n'entraient pas dans les foyers
français sous la troisième et quatrième
République ont fumée dans l'hémicycle on
se voyait à peine tellement c'était et
donc le cette
dérive là le premier effet c'est que les
Français en sont à base
et que sa mine l'idée qu'ils se font de
la démocratie et il y a un deuxième
effet c'est que les parlementaires sont
déstabilisés désabusés et pour certains
désespérés
je pense que c'est une c'est un c'est
une très mauvaise pente et cette pente
si on pouvait essayer d'y échapper ce
serait la moindre des choses qu'on
pourrait faire
d'exemplarités du gouvernement
l'occurrence qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait
faire Elisabeth borne a fait une forme
de rappels
pour faire des polémiques avec sur un un
geste ou une personne ou plusieurs
personnes ou un groupe je dis simplement
que la pente qui a été prise est une
pente dangereuse pour tout le monde je
suis stupéfait j'ai jamais entendu
autant de députés
qui disent
c'est le contraire de ce que j'attendais
je me reconnais pas du tout dans tout ça
et il y a là c'est la première fois que
je vois ça depuis très longtemps il y a
là quelque chose que nous ne devrions
pas accepter donc comment on fait
comment on fait il y a probablement des
réformes très importantes à faire
qui ne peuvent se faire qu'avec l'accord
de tous les groupes
ou en tout cas de d'une grande majorité
des groupes pour changer le mode de
fonctionnement des assemblées on vient
de voir encore ça dérape au Sénat et
pourtant le Sénat c'était comment
dirais-je
civilisées
et parfois
comment dirais-je
amical et un club disait-on et
aujourd'hui on en vient au même
difficulté ou même excès et donc je
pense que
sanctionnés à l'intérieur de l'émission
ils sont pas membres de l'assemblée il y
a quand même encore je sais bien que
voilà il y a aucun principe n'est plus
aucun principe n'est plus n'est plus
respectés mais il y a quand même la
séparation des pouvoirs qui fait que
normalement membre du gouvernement ne
peut pas
sanctionner un député et les députés
peuvent pas sanctionner un membre du
gouvernement alors la réforme des
retraites comment est-ce que vous avez
jugé le mouvement de protestation d'hier
et puis les grèves reconductibles qui
s'annoncent pour les jours qui viennent
le mouvement de protestation d'hier vous
voyez bien ce que c'est c'est un peu
au-dessous de ce que les syndicats
avaient annoncé
ville par ville
et en tout cas pas le grand blocage qui
avait été promis par certains
ça ne veut pas dire du tout que ça soit
une victoire pour le gouvernement
c'est d'une certaine manière je pense
pour certains des organisateurs un peu
décevants et parce qu'ils attendaient il
avait dit sur tous les tons une immense
vague la plus importante depuis la
guerre et puis l'arrêt de tout le de
toute la vie du pays qu'on allait mettre
l'économie à genoux enfin toutes ces
choses qu'on avait entendues qui étaient
d'ailleurs un peu naïve sans doute ou
qui était du wish full thinking comme on
dit des vœux des souhaits mais
ça n'est pas parce que ça n'était pas la
vague de rejet annoncé qui avait dans
beaucoup de secteurs moins de grévistes
que prévu ce n'est pas pour autant un
succès pour le gouvernement alors vous
avez dit depuis le début vous avez été
très sévère avec la communication du
gouvernement le manque de pédagogie sur
cette sur cette réforme
beaucoup d'opposants ont dit qu'elle
était inutile cette réforme qu'elle
était injustifiée que les comptes
étaient équilibrés et que tout cela
était une forme de caprice du prince
pour marquer son quinquennat c'est ce
que vous vouliez dire aussi
je regrette beaucoup que qu'on n'est pas
présenté aux Français la vérité de la
situation et la vérité des arguments
parce que le cette espèce de d'habileté
qui a fait que tous les responsables
n'avaient avant que le plan
d'intervienne pour donner des chiffres
qui n'ont été contredis par personne
tout le monde disait au fond
c'est un déficit de quelques milliards
ou dizaines
de milliards dans 10 ans donc c'est pas
grave il y a pas le feu au lac comme
certains disaient et tout ça est une
vaste blague parce que la vérité qui est
scandaleuse
qui devrait être honteuse pour les
générations qui sont au pouvoir et pour
les générations même qui sont
qui sont en situation de responsabilité
aujourd'hui la vérité c'est qu'il y a
d'ores et déjà au moins 30 milliards
d'euros de déficits par an que ces 30
milliards d'euros sont compensés par le
gouvernement
30 milliards d'euros c'est 30
000 millions hein d'euros tous les ans
30 000 millions d'euros tous les ans on
va passer les milliards et au fond on
fait pas de grandes différences entre
les milliards et les millions mais il
n'a pas suffisamment
danger laissez-moi ajouter une phrase
que le goût que l'État le gouvernement
l'exécutif décide de compenser les
déficits des retraites soit
et ça pourrait être une discussion
utile et intéressante si ces milliards
là on les avait
le problème qui doit faire honte aux
générations de responsables aujourd'hui
et ça n'a pas été expliqué aux Français
et j'arrive jamais à comprendre pourquoi
ce n'est pas expliqué
le problème c'est que ces milliards là
nous ne les avons pas nous les
empruntons tous les ans ce qui fait
regardez que
pour payer les pensions d'aujourd'hui on
charge les générations actives
d'aujourd'hui et de demain qui vont
avoir des centaines de milliards à
rembourser sans avoir le premier sous
pour le faire mais donc on est dans une
situation
d'irresponsabilité absolue et j'espère
que on va échapper en partie parce que
on n'est pas encore au chiffre de très
loin j'espère qu'on va échapper en
partie à cette irresponsabilité en
allant vers un meilleur déséquilibre
mais alors ce que vous dites quand même
si si je vous suis c'est que la réforme
telle qu'elle est présentée elle est
insuffisante parce qu'elle devrait
réunir 17 milliards dont 6 milliards de
mesure d'accompagnement en 2030 enfin
par an et et insuffisante et si on se
préoccupait de la dette du pays et de la
charge que cette dette représente pour
les plus jeunes non mais c'est déjà
refusé pourtant et pourtant vous-même
par exemple lorsque le président Macron
a voulu et faire passer cette réforme
des retraites en novembre sous la forme
d'un projet de loi de finance
rectificative assez rapide vous avez dit
la forme d'un amendement oui je m'y suis
opposé parce que ça ne se fait pas comme
ça la démocratie qu'est-ce que c'est le
personne n'y pense plus jamais la
démocratie s'est considérée que les
citoyens sont co-responsables de
l'avenir
qui sont pas des sujets à qui on donne
des ordres ils obéissent pas des
injonctions mais ils sont des décideurs
qui ont suivi là les manifestants sont
toujours aussi nombreux sinon plus dans
les rues qu'est-ce qu'il y a qu'est-ce
qui n'a pas marché qu'est-ce qui a raté
qu'est-ce qui si on avait donné aux
Français cette réalité ou présentée aux
Français la réalité telle que je viens
de l'exposer
alors je pense que ils auraient les
Français de même
pris le parti d'une réforme sérieuse et
courageuse mais
c'est pas les habitudes ont été prises
depuis longtemps les institutions
diverses et variées
ils ont voulu ils ont compris que
c'était peu accepté d'avoir de pouvoir
travailler deux ans de plus et il dit
c'est une réforme qui est juste et qui
va vers le progrès c'est comme ça que ça
a été annoncé
équitable donc une réforme juste parce
qu'elle partage la charge en ne laissant
pas aux générations qui viennent
le
l'obligation de signer d'échec pour les
pensions actuelles ceci n'est jamais
expliqué
comme si au fond on s'était habitués
à une situation qui fait que tous les
ans nous plombons entre 30 et 40
milliards d'euros supplémentaires la
dette de la France est-ce que c'est
acceptable nous sommes père et mère de
famille vous et moi
est-ce que c'est acceptable est-ce qu'on
peut regarder le les générations les
plus jeunes dans les yeux et en plus
les les enfin le leur proposer ou leur
enjoindre de venir manifester pour
défendre une situation qui plombe leur
situation pour très longtemps
vous savez que j'ai fait le président
Macron aurait dû le prononcer
j'aime pas donner des leçons de
l'extérieur je j'essaie de j'essaie de
m'appliquer à moi-même la règle trouvons
des arguments enfin trouvons
on aurait dû trouver à la fin là on est
à la fin du processus encore quand nous
ça jamais si la fin du processus est
vraiment la fin mais je dis que nous ne
devrions pas accepter de voir la
situation du pays les les
milliers de milliards qui constitue la
dette de la France s'aggraver encore
par une une
ignorance ou une volonté de cacher ou de
ne pas regarder en face les choses alors
concrètement si on était à la fin c'est
à dire que normalement la semaine
prochaine le projet de loi va revenir du
Sénat à l'Assemblée nationale par le
biais de la commission mixte paritaire
par un texte commun est-ce que le modem
et de députés
et de déléguer des sénateurs
d'un seul homme d'une seule femme
ce projet vous êtes 51 député il y aura
pas une voix qui manquera je crois que
non
est-ce que ce projet passera à votre
avis à l'Assemblée nationale est-ce
qu'il aura une majorité ça dépend il
faut vous savez les procédures c'est
compliqué le gouvernement va avoir le
choix entre deux attitudes soumettre le
texte au vote auquel cas il passe avec
des voix positives faut voter pour qu'il
pour qu'il passe ou bien choisir ce
qu'on appelle 49 3 qui est une autre
procédure parlementaire qui fait que
le texte est adopté sauf
autrement dit les institutions disent au
parlementaire écoutez vous pouvez
laisser passer le texte
autrement c'est une émotion de censure
qui renverse le gouvernement je sais pas
si on voit dans quelle situation
institutionnelle on se trouverait donc
moi je crois que le gouvernement va
faire son choix je ne sais pas à l'heure
qu'il est quel choix il va faire ce que
ça dépend de l'ambiance mercredi
prochain au moment de la commission
mixte paritaire
si c'est un 49-3 c'est une forme de
hold-up démocratique et on continuera
les manifestations
Laurent Berger dans les dans les dans
les polémiques dans les périodes tendues
on utilise des mots on choisit des
expressions
qui parfois dépasse sa pensée ça peut
arriver au meilleur d'entre nous si
c'était le 49-3 bah ça ne ça ne vous
choquerait pas au sens c'est une arme
institutionnelle je rappelle que Rocard
y compris sur des textes de ce genre n'a
utilisé plusieurs dizaines de fois
aujourd'hui dans la concision il est
utilisable que qu'une fois pour un
projet enfin pour les projets de budget
et une seule fois pour d'autres projets
donc ce serait ça vous choquerait pas
finalement ça ne j'ai jamais trouvé je
sais bien que c'est la mode d'abord
parce qu'on sait pas très bien ce que
c'est ça un nom mystérieux le parce que
tout le monde est pas familier de des
débats institutionnels n'est-ce pas non
pour moi ça n'est pas un hold-up c'est
une démarche de prudence
quand vous choisissez le 49-3 quand vous
êtes pas absolument sûr de la majorité
c'est pas un hold-up c'est une prudence
et c'est une prudence qui montre que
personne et tout à fait certain de la
situation et des rapports de force après
aujourd'hui déjà les syndicats
reprochent à Emmanuel Macron et au
gouvernement de ne pas dialoguer
suffisamment de ne pas discuter d'être
sourd comment on sort de sa situation
alors c'est une situation beaucoup plus
large que ça c'est la société française
tout entière qui est aujourd'hui dans
une espèce de de soupçons de doute de
mise en cause de des règles que nous
nous sommes données nous-mêmes pour
vivre ensemble pour faire fonctionner
la souveraineté populaire
et on ne peut en sortir à mon avis que
en choisissant deux attitudes et je dis
pas que ça sera facile la première
attitude c'est
reformuler un projet pour le pays qui
s'attaque au plus difficile de nos
faiblesses ou au plus pénalisante de nos
faiblesses
et nos faiblesses vous savez bien on a
de très gros problèmes d'éducation on a
de très gros problèmes
d'industrialisation
on l'a fait il y a moins d'un an et bien
donc peut-être que ce qui n'a pas été
formulé au moment de l'élection
présidentielle devrait être repris
aujourd'hui à frais nouveau
contrats avec les Français je suis
persuadé de ça c'est une expression que
vous souvenez j'avais utilisé il y a des
années dans dans la mission de ministre
de l'Éducation j'avais fait un nouveau
contrat pour l'école c'est une
expression que le Président de la
République avait reprises dans la
période des gilets jaunes un nouveau
contrat avec les Français faire un
nouveau contrat et les gens disent ça y
est c'est passé
tous les ans mais ce n'est pas sur les
retraites
que que je que j'essaie de braquer le
projecteur
on est un pays en panne
c'est pour beaucoup de Français
désespérant
on se rend pas compte mais il y a vous
savez l'abstention par exemple ça n'est
que le symptôme de ce désespoir là de
cette de cette éloignement des Français
de la réalité politique parce qu'ils
pensent au fond de même que la politique
est impuissante à changer des choses
fondamentales le président proposerait
aux Français pour avancer et sortir
d'une séquence très difficile
[Musique]
et que pour moi
toutes les forces sociales et politiques
devraient d'une certaine manière
préparer ensemble même si on est en
désaccord profond pour le moment et
parce que canaux de discussion
l'idée de la démocratie que je défends
alors peut-être c'est idéaliste l'idée
de la démocratie que je défense c'est
pas l'affrontement systématique j'ai
toujours été opposé à l'affrontement
systématique on sait que avant qu'ils
ouvrent la bouche on sait ce qu'ils vont
dire ceux qui sont dans la majorité sont
pour ceux qui sont dans l'opposition
sont contre et c'est ridicule et ça nous
a conduit à la situation où on est si
vous regardez les pays qui se portent
bien c'est des pays dans lesquels on a
su faire vivre le dialogue le le
l'entente le gouvernement quand même le
gouvernement prétend et bien il est bien
non seulement qu'il le prétendent mais
qu'on avance sur ce sujet parce que pour
moi conçoit dans la majorité ou dans
l'opposition
conçoit dans un syndicat qu'on soit dans
les syndicats ou dans les organisations
économiques patronales on est
co-responsable de l'avenir du pays alors
est-ce qu'Emmanuel Macron devrait parler
avec Laurent Berger très rapidement je
trouverai que c'est une très bonne idée
mais pas seulement avec Laurent Berger
c'est pas le seul responsable syndical
même si c'est
le grand courant réformiste auquel je
suis pour ma part très attaché donc vous
pensez qu'il devrait y avoir un dialogue
assez rapide
pour sortir de cette séquence difficile
entre le président et les syndicats les
plus précisément
quand cette séquence sera accomplie
j'espère qu'elle le sera sans drame et
sans casse alors oui sera temps d'ouvrir
une page nouvelle et c'est la
responsabilité du Président de la
République de l'ouvrir et c'est la
responsabilité de tous ceux qui sont
partis prenantes de la réflexion sur
l'avenir du pays d'en prendre dans leur
part que chacun s'exprime et disent ce
qu'il attendrait vous avez parlé
ça m'arrive assez souvent
donc vous pensez que ça fait partie des
nouveaux enfin dans ce nouveau contrat
il faut remettre ces liens alors je vais
je vais vous redire les choses je les ai
souvent dites y compris à votre micro
il y a en France
un grand courant réformiste c'est un
courant
démocrate et social
social-démocrate démocrate de toute
sensibilité ce grand courant là à la
responsabilité de faire évoluer le pays
et nous avons la responsabilité
de ne pas laisser ce courant se diviser
c'est le cas aujourd'hui de façon très
nette c'est le cas aujourd'hui et je
pense pas que ça soit une bonne chose je
pense moi que tous ceux qui ont cette
sensibilité il n'y a pas que la CFDT il
y a d'autres syndicats
la CFTC l'une ça des organisations
patronales qui ont marqué très souvent
faux quelquefois aussi qui ont marqué
très souvent leur attachement à cette
vision de l'avenir il y a des syndicats
qui choisissent la confrontation c'est
le cas de la CGT c'est le cas de dessus
en tout cas dans certaines expressions
ce sont des syndicats qui pensent que le
mieux est d'organiser la confrontation
mais le grand courant réformiste du pays
qui a son expression dans le monde
syndical et dans le monde politique
le courant dans lequel je me reconnais
ce courant là il a une responsabilité
particulière et il devrait avoir la
responsabilité de ne pas se diviser ou
de se diviser le moins possible merci
merci beaucoup bah le message s'adresse
autant au syndicat que au président et
au gouvernement à mon avis vous voulez
dire que c'est un message j'ai entendu
ça merci beaucoup d'être venu sur notre